[Musik]
asknet willkommen beim ein video
ich weiß nicht ich anfangen soll ich
weiß wir das nicht megabyte knapp auf
den zweiten teil von die möglichkeiten
braten alter kraft ja der erste teil ist
auf jeden fall beim ein abonnenten also
bei euch ziemlich gut ankommen hat mich
sehr gefreut haben ziemlich vielen
daumen nach oben da gelassen und ihr
habt doch wirklich sehr sehr viele
kommentar geschrieben was ich denn noch
beraten soll
und da war dann zum beispiel so
kommentare dabei wird ich glaube der
meiste kommentare schippmann ich
verraten und da das ist eine sache gut
ich einzig was mit denen passiert
ich fand also tut mir leid ersten können
aber mal sehen wer gebraten schmeckt
dann hab ich auch wirklich sehr sehr auf
den kommentar gelesen dass ich doch
einfach mal im moment super zutaten soll
die kleine raum ein
keine ahnung ob überhaupt was passiert
mit denen ich habe jetzt mal kaufte und
wir versuchen einfach mal und zum
schluss habe ich meine eigene
kreativität auch mal ein bisschen spiel
machen und haben hier nochmal topform
uns gekauft mit dieser erfüllung wenn
ich weiter mit die kinder man so eine
anerkannte liegt also man weißt du drauf
und dann macht das
ganz starke leistung
du bist echt ich gucke von oben braucht
ihn da diesem fall so dumm kann er auch
nur wie ich sein
die habe ich gestern schon angefangen
weil ich irgendwie vom markt mit denen
sorgt jetzt hier habe ich auch noch eine
neue fahne gekauft weil die fahne die
ich letztes mal benutzt hat die ist
jetzt leider nicht mehr für normale
lebensmittel zu gebrauchen leute sagen
was den auftakt macht das ganze noch ein
drittes mal und schreibt auch wieder in
die kommentare
was euch noch beraten ich bin gespannt
und ich will ganz lang lagern wir
vergangen und laptop wirklich bei kurzer
pause und schaut bei instagram vorbei
der kommerz in zukunft neue coole bilder
also alles wie ein bisschen verändert
aber es geht los
heute ich bin jetzt in der küche ich
würde mal sagen vielleicht die letzte
mal hier in die kameras die für mich auf
die party geht jetzt auch rechnung
und dann kann ich wieder loslege
leistung ich war schockiert ich wünsche
ganz viel spaß und ich stellen kamera
wieder ich denke wieder dahin
also kann ich an speed prozessen zwei
vorkommen kann man nicht so viel
erwarten also gefährt machen will hier
in die falle
deswegen habe ich es allein schon wieder
viel zu viel genommen aber was soll's
ein wenig länger auf die wäre einfach
ich hab ihm ein gutes buch total
vergessen
die leute ich mag ihr hertha kurze
fragen der tierhaltung zum backen von
monty also wirklich unser erstes produkt
aus dem parlament
da will ich weiter meine linie die
kubatur und laptop
da sucht man auf das ist doch egal nur
einmal rüber kommt ich mag es so gerne
okay das wäre selbst vergessen machen
wer gar nicht wenn ich das hier ist auf
jeden fall hier sicherlich die farbe
okay gab einer wiedererkannt ist jetzt
fertig guten appetit
wir machen weiter an fahrt kommen roten
höhepunkt hier viel länger gespannt was
passiert wette mit chips alltag also
kamera gefieder jährigen
naja und vorne stufe
mal gucken was die zu machen ein
bisschen höhe so in das ganze kommt
einfach etwas sein das auf jeden fall
sehr gewichtigen bereits machen so und
hier will ich als ganzes fahrvereins
werden
einfach passiert es wohl deshalb so muss
man sagen da passiert ja ich weiß viele
noch jetzt meine kommentare die meldung
hat mich die ganze zeit lang darüber
wachen aber glücklich machen mich wie
eine harte reaktion will deswegen erst
kurz nach monaco legal wenn mich jemand
fragt ob du noch youtube und user guckt
euch mal an wie die einfach aussehen der
prämierten produzenten
ich bin mehr weiter zu verkennen wir
wahrscheinlich auch bekommt
aber hier die käufer wieder voll stellt
aus oder nicht komplett am boden ein
mal sehen wir jetzt was ihr aber nicht
nur
[Musik]
also für den pfosten so luther haus wenn
sie geraten sind 8 uhr und für die mama
wissen wollten wie lol ich viele aus dem
wenn man wie gebraten hat ungefähr so
ende gatti verformen sich oder die
berkel einfach nun länger als wir sehen
uns auf jeden fall gleich wieder dann
probiert das ganze und bis leicht so
leicht jetzt bekommen oder dass ein
bisschen hell oder durch rudolf kurz
wird umgestellt sind jetzt ein paar
klamotten von mir ich wollte einfach
nicht mehr dass der heftige pendler die
ganze braucht deswegen machen jetzt so
weiter erste versuche klappen wird schon
sagen kann man kaum ertragen oder hat
jetzt auf jeden fall aber hier den
teller mit den leckeren sachen also ja
mal die gebratenen chips hier haben wir
die gebratenen jupa jobs hier haben wir
die gebratenen dem freibad und hier
haben wir die gebratenen m und 1
bratkartoffeln okay ich würde sagen ich
fahre ganz traditionell mal an wie ich
eben angefangen hat und zwar mit denen
im zwei ballons das sind die hier diesem
festgeklebt also leute ein gebratenes
nimm2 bonbons letzter
castrol ich halte das war richtig sauer
war das war laura kann man essen für
herhalten cyberone sprachen kein problem
jetzt glaube ich das ist das eklig für
und zwar guckt euch das mal an hier hier
vorne das sind einfach dass da
gebratenem und mvg leute ich probiert
jemand deswegen flecker junge mann oder
kann man es noch tipps alter den hin
der ist einfach eine mischung aus
geworden öl und sahne und tschüss
[Musik]
da ist nichts passiert einfach
so leute kommen wir zu den super job die
hälfte von ihnen ist geschmolzen nicht
weiter aber wir probieren es einfach mal
hier den ich glaube dass hier müsste
erdbeer sein wenn die zelle
ja da ist dass das öl nicht so rein
gezogen also leichte der tipp mit dem
thema zwar nicht so gut ich bin gerne
mit jüngster zeit egal
das sagt in dem video ich hoffe
natürlich einfach durchgefallen falls
dies der fall war ich würd sagen es gibt
natürlich auch ein 2 3 bei 15.000 nike
angesetzt wird also wenn man das
schaffen die zeit reicht wenn ich noch
einen angenehmen tag
checkmate instagram ab und wir sind uns
dann am sonntag wieder um 14 uhr
ansonsten bis sonntag
haut rein